in this lesson you'll learn how to
optimize your pages for different screen
sizes including the difference between
CSS and device-independent pixels and
how to choose the right sizes for your
elements and at the end of the lesson
you'll build the mobile version of the
hometown site now when I'm working on my
sites sometimes I noticed that content
seems to flow off the page or I have to
pinch and zoom to see anything what's
going on here
well besides your CSS which could use a
little bit of work the biggest problem
is that you don't have the viewport set
properly the viewport defines the area
of the screen that the browser can
render content to here let me show you
an example in my laptop I've sized the
browser window to 800 pixels wide which
makes my viewport 800 pixels if I expand
the width the viewport size changes and
now I have a viewport width of a
thousand pixels all right well that
seems simple enough but not all displays
have the same pixel density right right
like what about something like your
Chromebook pixel display right well the
Chromebook pixel display tells me that
it's got a width of 2560 pixels by 1700
pixels but when I make the browser
window the full width and ask for the
viewport width it tells me it's only
1280 pixels wide weight not the full
2560 nope not at all hmm well not all
pixels were created equal were they
exactly a pixel isn't always a pixel